gratz on sandy Wexler a very funny movie
thank you very much you play it's funny
I didn't know what part you was before I
saw the show what part you would play
and you play a trapeze daredevil
daredevil yeah and sandy Wexler is a
sort of a down-on-his-luck manager not a
lot of successful clients you're not a
great daredevil in this in this movie
no he a sailor plays the manager he has
this kind of ragtag group of clients and
yeah I play like a kind of a low-rent
Evel Knievel and I and I do um I started
doing as many of my own stunts as I
could and the movies because I always
hate when you're watching a movie you
can tell when it's now the actors so I
tried to like put myself out there and
do stopping so I was doing a lot of the
trapeze myself and stuff is cool and
then I got cocky
which this horrible idea yeah so there
was a scene where I got lit on fire and
so the guy goes all right I'm gonna
light your legs on fire it's gonna
spread up to give it two seconds and
then go off the trapeze land and we'll
put you out right so it's like all right
so then then I thought you know what
what if I give it five seconds make it
look real cool yeah here's one thing you
don't get cocky with fire yeah not a
good idea so it lights me on fire one
two let's keep it going three four and
the guy goes run up my back and I just
like this bollocks there's ball of
flames they put me out it's like what
are you doing I was like I don't know I
got cocky he's like yeah let's not get
cocky did you get hurt at all no I was
hot
yeah real hot yeah I understand cuz I
thought I heard that you got hurt and I
think it was like around the time you
were making the movie and I assumed it
was doing a stunt no I did I banged up
my knee really bad and you would think
it would have been from a stunt but I
fell off karaoke stage
is that true you really did fall off a
karaoke stage yeah how did you manage
that
I wasn't even singing which is even more
embarrassing wait yeah my friend was
singing and I was on the side of the
stage and I had to pee and the bathroom
was on the other side of the stage so
instead of going in front of it I
decided to cross the stage and then I
got caught in the curtain and then I
just wiped out and you needed like kids
you really hurt your knee yeah I landed
right on my knee and then I in front of
the entire crowd and then my buddy I was
like afterwards I made anybody see that
he was like no no you're cool and then I
like kind of limped out of the bathroom
and the whole crowd is just like 70
people super stupid
you